For the purpose of giving students more opportunities to speak that Japanese.
We are doing a Japanese lunch table. The
lunch table is mit Japan. This program is
Japan.  I have that function of sending a student who is speaking a language to
Japan as an internship in the summer, but
I do it once a week with this mit Japan program
. Students are at this lunch table.  It
's a native Japanese person other than the teacher.
This is
not only that country, mit Japan, but that person. There is an eye group called Prince Wipe Scrub, which
receives a lot of support from foreign body clubs.
Well, mit's Japanese program
or its cultural course related to Japanese is to improve verity that day.
Well, we usually hold an event called Japanet mit at
the beginning of each semester.  However,
the Japanese mit is like a party, but what
we do at that event is an overview of the Japanese language program, and
the courses related to Japanese culture offered at mit,
such as the anime course
and then Pocker-chan.  There are various courses like that,
but
I would like to introduce them. Then, the vibes club often helps me, but
t cell also introduced my brother, changed my kimono, and so
on.  to introduce